[Music]
thank you
let's talk about this glitter conspiracy
uh I'm down let's theorize about this
the world is running out of glitter and
nobody knows why except for this woman
can you tell me what your biggest fire
is
no I absolutely know that
okay but you know what it is oh
this is a reenactment of a conversation
between a New York Times journalist and
a manager at one of the largest glitter
companies in the world why can't you
tell me she responds from a non-descript
warehouse in Suburban New Jersey because
they don't want anyone to know that it
is glitter thousands and thousands of
people have been trying to solve this
all across the world they can't they
found evidence and I will say there's
some really strange nuances in the
details here but that's for another time
because right now the real answer is is
we don't know where the glitter is going
we don't know who the this makes me
laugh because I saw
a similar thing hot dogs
I'm sorry sorry I got carried away
let me let me let me get back to the
point yep
chicken yeah yeah okay sorry keep going
no I'm just laughing at this editing
style because I saw another thing about
um
it was some documentary oh it was a
documentary about future and Sierra okay
and how Sierra and like Russell Wilson
like their relationship is some weird
celebrity gossip there okay and all the
comments were going bro why did they
make it seem like future murdered Sierra
like we just had a kid together yeah
that's true sort of editing this [ __ ] is
huge like homemade documentary style
stuff now is huge yeah on YouTube on
Tick Tock you can make anything seem
super dramatic when you edit it like
that yeah
on October 31st
Noel sat down to drink a glass of milk
unbeknownst to him a strange chemical
reaction was going on I'm [ __ ] water
Noel called to his girlfriend and said
babe wife whoops
sorry
he called out to his wife and said babe
the milk is getting Juiced in my tummy
but she was asleep yeah
okay all right what do you think it is
you think it's hot dogs yeah
it's hot dogs
because they're all like you know they
look so tasty
and they're like a little shiny
you know
yeah and they're they're beautiful hot
dogs do look moist I would actually be
I'd be more
on board with that they purchase
Vaseline
that they grease up the dogs before they
package them oh oh I think the glitter
was in the Vaseline no no oh you're
saying they grease up the yeah the dogs
okay
glitter dog now think about what glitter
is okay it's it refracts it's small
little specks yeah
there were some a couple interesting
suggestions there like I saw uh like
explosives was one of them that kind of
makes sense yeah
you know like grenades and [ __ ] like
that oh that'd be interesting if yeah if
an actual explosion doesn't produce that
much
visual effect and they inject it with
glitter so it
it just adds to the chaos yeah maybe
just uh yeah no if I looked at it I
wouldn't know that it was glitter no not
really
would I be able to see the glitter oh
you'd be able to see something but it's
yeah I can't what about like countertops
yeah like marble and so it's always like
a little bit shiny maybe it's like fake
yeah something to make something look
more
high class and
High Caliber no
oh okay
no I'm saying I'm saying no because
there's no shame in that right it's got
It's Something shameful yes you're right
it is something that they want to yeah
hide yeah so Reddit a couple years ago
when this article first came out really
dug into it and they didn't come to a
solid answer but well we know red it's
really good at sleuthing things yeah the
same way they found the Boston Bomber
one of the leading theories is glitter
is inside of explosives so that they can
track it down later and figure out where
it came from what they like put unique
glitter in different types of explosives
yeah sort of to know like what was used
where mostly based on like the source of
where it comes from so one like
Department of Defense Contractor will
have a type of glitter that they put in
their explosives so then if it's used
elsewhere they can track it down yeah
they're made the same way as glitter so
people think that Glitter X is just
making it for them that's not fun I like
hot dogs better yeah that's boring I'm
struggling to think of anything that's
consumable
peanut butter
it's not actually chunky nuts in there
it's just glitter
damn what was that
I don't know
who was that
little little ghost over there yeah
seems Seems as such Halloween's not over
who eats these
okay that's scary man don't do that
that is scary did you hear that Wilhelm
scream yeah did you play that no play
what
hear what
are you talking about
there was a scary sound in my ears
Geary was there actually stop dude
Halloween's [ __ ] over it's done
it's November 1st
what are you talking about dude why you
keep saying stop like that because
there's music playing
[Laughter]
no
foreign
stop talking about the glitter
are you you're eating it
huh
yeah you're like no one eats these
Hershey's yeah that [ __ ] is weird man
weird right that's serial killer [ __ ]
right there wait speaking of serial
killers let me just completely
mischaracterize an innocent person okay
I used to eat at this Diner after like
working late nights at Best Buy I mean
my friends
and on some nights
there was this dude who worked at
Disneyland and I think he worked a night
shift or something
because we'd get there at this Diner
around
I don't know 1 32 in the morning
and that's when he was showing up okay
or it might have been after a shift I
don't know but he'd be in Disneyland
clothing
this [ __ ] would bring a massive
bowl of a homemade egg salad
and he just sit at the bar of the diner
and eat it to himself while watching the
TV it was the
can you bring can you bring in homemade
food it he did wait was he working at
the diner no he was like in Disneyland
like work clothing okay like he had a
name tag he was a cast member no
he wasn't no okay
maybe he worked in their cafeteria or I
don't know what aren't they all cast
members though technically or no you
have to be like part of this oh sorry I
thought cast member is you know you're
one of the I think if you're a Disney
Employee they call you a cast member oh
my bad
so yes yeah okay he was a cast member he
would sit there and pile drive this huge
bowl of egg salad and I remember his
face and his demeanor I'd always think
of this dude and I'd think this guy is
gonna kill somebody okay it was it was
just like the most off-putting Vibe this
Diner was old as hell
it just dude pulling up at 2AM with your
bowl and he would eat it like this
he was like his arms like protecting him
he'd be like head down okay can I get a
bite would you mind if I could
he'd sit alone at the corner yeah bro
he had beaver teeth for sure he had a
beaver to he had a beaver mouth you see
this Mr Beast yeah raising money yeah at
a 1.5 which actually doesn't surprise me
at all yeah because he
he told us that you know he he uh
he got an offer for a billion dollars
and now he's trying to raise that 1.5
billion dollars valuation
but it I mean it's just like what do you
think he's gonna do with the money
uh just grow his team like crazy do
squid games three yeah
he's the one behind the golfer glitter
yeah yeah
he doesn't want you to know all those
people are made of glitter they're not
real people now he's buying it all for
something yeah
we've made the biggest glitter bomb
exactly or all his candies made of
glitter we're gonna flood the ocean
with glitter the Alaskan oil spill has
gone on
ugly way too yeah we're gonna make that
[ __ ] it's time to make it pretty
we're gonna spray these hundreds of
thousands of penguins with glitter
we're gonna Glam up these
we're working with Sephora
we've partnered with Sephora for this
video
to absolutely Glam these animals
claminals